by
why did you come out here today I'm an
atheist and this is the largest
gathering of secular people in the
history of the world because I am a free
thinker I'm a humanist I'm actually a
leader in the humanist movement Pete is
out here cuz so many wonderful you know
free thinking people here a lot of
people that are interested in all sorts
of different issues and you know we hope
that non-human animals are one of them
can you tell me why you came out here
today the blood of Jesus cleanses us
from all sin all right um so why are you
out here today to let the Religious
Right know that they got to know where
they hand and we begin they have no
right to force their religion on the
rest of us why did you come out today I
came out today uh for a reason and for
three free thought and because it's we
don't see a lot of that in our town why
did you come out here today I like to
engage in civil debate rather than argue
like there's all bunch of people
protesting what we're doing all up and
down the street I believe evolution is a
lie I believe it's a it's a big
deception to dumb you down to BOTS get
you into a new world order eventually so
you know if you don't believe that's
what Hitler believed Hitler believed in
evolution since you don't believe in God
what is stopping you from killing
everyone right now why would you kill
some it's because you don't believe in
God um this is not right
can you explain your fantastic ensemble
for me I get mistaken for this mythical
Creek being Jesus all the time but it's
really just me where do you get your
morals without God why aren't you
killing everybody and stealing and
things like that don't need morals I
have an ethics um what do you think of
these people out here the blood of Jesus
cleanses from awesome God that's
deceiving us yeah
that's not necessary maybe God is bored
sitting up there in the clouds and likes
to mess with us are people being hostile
to you
yes very much so because you know they
they have a love for nothing in their
heart for no hope that they're just
finite existing and then they're
destroyed they're not going to think
anymore one day that they just go into
the ground there's no hope in that is it
meaningless no it's the one life we have
you have to give it all the meaning
are you um in favor of the religious
right-wing we're from a libertarian
group actually also you're a tea party
member no no no not that this is saying
that you know Obama is not going to make
any kind of legislation or or any push
to to teach our kids in early Earth or
young Earth Creationism or or anything
like that have you been talking to
atheists today I still believe that the
blood of Jesus cleanses from awesome
you